if you're new to google cloud there is a
lot to absorb
especially if you're excited to get
started in any of the many tools out
there
like big data analytics kubernetes
serverless or machine learning i'm here
to break it all down so you can start
building things up right away
[Music]
so first things first cloud.google.com
is your starting point
this is where you will find information
about our products and offers
if you want to jump right in you can go
directly to the console
or search our documentation for quick
starts solutions
reference architectures and browse code
samples
you'll also find our latest offers
listed like free trials
pricing is also detailed there including
google's pricing list
a detailed cost calculator for every
google cloud product and service
and information on the free tier for
every applicable product
cloud.google.com is also the place to
access support
to read customer stories to find
partners
and understand how google cloud is
different from other public clouds
you'll also find helpful getting started
resources like
quick starts trainings and
certifications
but in my opinion the best way to really
get started
is the google cloud console this is
where you'll probably spend the most
time
exploring and using the platform it's
where you configure billing accounts
create and manage projects and manage
all of your google cloud resources
regardless of their data center location
every product and every service has its
own section
in the console left-hand menu with
dashboards
detailed configuration and settings
you'll also find interactive quick start
experiences
right from inside the console
take this example quickstart for compute
engine
right from here it'll show you exactly
where to go
in the console for each step and within
minutes
you'll be running a two-tier web
application running a python web server
running on compute engine
the cloud console also offers a
marketplace
with ready to go software stacks to
accelerate development
so you spend less time installing and
more time developing
this allows you to deploy production
grade solutions in
a few clicks with a single bill for all
of
your google cloud and third-party costs
and it also
offers direct access to partner support
to make sure you set up your employees
with the right permissions to use
different google cloud resources
cloud console integrates identity and
access management
or cloud iam and provides a unified view
into security policies across your
entire organization
this is also where you would manage
quotas across the platform
every product comes with one or more
usage limits across the platform
so you can prevent one team from
spending the entire orgs budget
on a rogue query or compute job
you can also use our ios and android
mobile apps
to monitor and manage your google cloud
applications
on the go lastly you can contact support
or sign up for support packages for both
development
and production phases right from the
console
role-based support enables configuration
on a per-user basis
and case management is integrated into
the cloud console
premium support offers additional
support and
faster response times for mission
critical workloads
if you'd like to know more about the
google cloud console
check out the links below while the
console
is powerful and flexible you can do
everything from the command line for
every action
in the console there is a gcloud
equivalent
gcloud is your scriptable and almighty
cli
and it comes with the google cloud sdk
you can do things like create resources
change configurations and grant
authorization
there are other command line tools for
products like
bigquery and gke the gcloud sdk
and these clis come pre-installed in
cloud shell
cloud shell is a shell environment
hosted on google cloud for
managing your projects and resources
it's accessible from a simple web
browser
and is powered by a small virtual
machine with persistent disk space
and up-to-date software for all of your
development needs
it even comes with a really handy web
code
editor if you'd like to know
more about developer tools check out the
links in the description
below now before you can use the google
cloud console
you will need a google account
you can create a new google account or
use an existing one such as your gmail
account
we recommend that you enable billing for
your project
and that you sign up for our free trial
but if you don't sign up for the free
trial or are unable to
you can still benefit from the generous
always free tier
once logged into the google cloud
console i recommend that you check out
the
main menu and in particular the getting
started section
check out the checklist to complete
common tasks like
creating a project finding products and
apis
and adding your very first resources
back on the getting started page scroll
down to the section
put google cloud to work and click on
browse interactive tutorials
this opens up a panel with a list of
tutorials of your product of choice
without leaving the console finally
check out the main categories of
products google cloud has to offer
compute storage
networking operations
tools big data
and artificial intelligence
as you progress through your discovery
of google cloud
keep in mind these key resources
documentation
can be found at cloud.google.com docs
in-depth architectural diagrams and
tutorials at
slash architecture code samples at
slash docs samples
support at slash support
training at slash training and free code
labs
at g dot co code labs slash cloud
google cloud can be a little
overwhelming at first
but with this guidance i hope that you
are now confident that your best ideas
can come to life
in the cloud i'm excited to see what you
build and i look forward to your
feedback
if you like this video please like
subscribe comment
and share this is stephanie wong i'll
see you all next time